[Music]
tons of apps are now using artificial
intelligence
and we don't always understand the
impacts of their algorithms
when you download an app on your phone
for example
you probably don't really read the terms
and conditions right
but what if you could look up a specific
app and see right away that its
algorithms are ethical and transparent
maybe on that long list of terms and
conditions you see a label
a stamp that says fair ai
the same way you now have like organic
fruit
you could have responsible algorithms
there's a lot of research actually
of how to verify if something
is fair and if it's not fair then how
can you
change it so that it becomes fair of
course verifying that algorithms are
ethical
is not always that straightforward
but this is just one idea a starting
point
in thinking about how we might regulate
ai
we're hearing more and more about issues
like privacy and accountability
and policymakers around the world have
started brainstorming solutions
so what does it really mean to create
responsible ai
it's about mitigating risks while
maximizing opportunities
[Music]
[Music]
when we think about the question of how
do we shape the use of ai in a way
that's going to be
really socially beneficial it's
important to remember that we have a
really big tool kit at our disposal
governments have had a lot of different
methods for creating policy
they have tools like laws taxes
subsidies and standards they also have
things like advertising and what's
called moral suasion the government is
more or less saying
you know this is what kind of good
people do
or you know is talking to tech companies
and encouraging them to
take on certain actions and behaviors
governments can also affect
the way that technology is developed
through their procurement methods
governments are one of the largest
purchasers of products in the entire
world and if they say
these are the standards by which we want
these products to adhere to
that creates a lot of pressure in the
market
lots of governments have started to
create policy to both regulate and
support the research and development of
ai
but these policies can look vastly
different from one country to the next
some countries like germany india and
the uk
have a more comprehensive strategy with
many focus areas
whereas others like south korea and
taiwan
have pushed for a more specific focus
canada is notable for a few reasons one
it was the first country in the world
to have a funded artificial intelligence
strategy which i think is quite notable
and gives me a little canadian pride
in 2017 the government of canada
invested 125 million dollars into a
national ai strategy
the first of its kind in the world the
pan canadian
artificial intelligence strategy was
launched in the spring of 2017.
cfar is a global research organization
that's based in canada
and cfar got asked to lead the national
artificial intelligence strategy so we
have three primary research centers
one in toronto one in montreal and one
in edmonton
early strategies like canada's focused
mainly on developing research
and talent in addition to the social
implications of ai
nowadays as this social impact continues
to grow
we need more strategic thinking around
policy solutions
this means considering how ai might
affect the public good
both now and in the future
there are a lot of efforts underway
right now in different jurisdictions
to try and control and regulate ai and
the gdpr in the eu is one really great
example which is
dedicated to protecting the privacy and
security of digital data
for european citizens that's the general
data protection regulation
which went into effect in 2018 it sets
guidelines for the collection
and processing of personal data from
individuals living across the european
union and we're seeing this all over the
world as well
for instance when we have different
municipalities all over the u.s who are
banning facial recognition technology
cities like san francisco california and
somerville massachusetts have
banned facial recognition from being
used by city departments
including the police they were concerned
about the accuracy
and bias of these systems because many
were unable to correctly recognize
people of color and
women there's a notion of privacy
there's a notion of security
there's the questions of fairness in
canada
the privacy commissioner launched an
investigation into clearview ai
a us-based company that was providing
facial recognition services to the rcmp
since then the company has pulled out of
the canadian market
examples like this show that when it
comes to regulation
governments have a huge role to play but
as ai becomes integrated into every
industry
we also need to think about how other
players might fit in
government is going to play a very
strong role we might see a ministry of
digital technology at
some point but governments cannot and
someone argue should not do it alone
companies healthcare sectors should also
be part of the conversation
governments are slow moving by nature
and they're very risk-averse
and so we can't rely on governments to
do this alone we need to draw on
insights from hospitals schools the
private sector
and even individual members of society
because what might be a solution in one
area
might not necessarily work for another i
think that
there definitely needs to be some
regulation of these technologies
but the appropriate way to handle that
is by looking at the specific sectors
and identifying sensitive sectors
whether it be
justice or healthcare or what have you
where regulation is critical we're still
just beginning the conversation about ai
policy
and that's the exciting part all of this
is new
so we can think outside the box it's a
technology
that if we don't think very carefully
about all the populations that it
could serve it could do a disservice to
then we're going to do the disservices
because once deployed it's going to
impact everybody's
lives we need to get creative in order
to respond more effectively to the fast
pace of technological innovation
for policy makers this means considering
the tools that are already out there
and tailoring them for ai tools like
skills and training programs
research investment consumer protections
or public engagement
and even those of us who aren't writing
code can still be part of the
conversation
when we're looking at how to set speed
limits on roads
you don't need to really know how a
catalytic converter works in order to do
that
so i don't think it's that important
that people need to know
the really detailed mechanics of how
these algorithms actually work
in order to have an opinion on it ai has
the potential to do amazing things
and for the greater good as well we just
need to think about how to do it
responsibly and
to protect the most vulnerable and
marginalized people along the way
[Music]
rapid development of ai has brought
about huge progress
it's also raised crucial questions about
how we move forward as a society
as research continues innovation will
flourish
and as we look for solutions there
should be no limit to our creativity
because how we act now is what will
shape our collective future
[Music]
[Music]
you